WE PLAYED SOME CONNECT FOUR,
BUT WE NEED
AWAY WE GO.PLAYS IT UP THE WHOL
OFFENSIVE SO FAR EARLY IN THIS
SEASON.
THIS TEAM IS BUILT ON DEFE
THERE, IT IS SO MUCH MORE
MAGNIFIED.   UP, SAVE
MADE BY PETERSEN.
FORECHECK, CREATED THE TURNOVER
AND THEN IT GOT ININ
COMIC HE WAS RIGHT ON THE BRINK
OF WHEN YOU SHOULD DO
DEFLECTED THERE
CONTROLLING THERE IS FABBRO.
JOSI COMING IN SAID HE
WANTED HIS TEAM TO GET TO
FORCING SAROS TO MAKE A GREAT
SAVE.
JOSI WITH THE POWER PLAY GOAL V
FIRST WIN OF THE YEAR.THE MIDDL
SKI RAMPED
>> Willy: TOO FAR FOR
HIM.
LET'S LOOK AT THE . OVER
FOR FORSBERG AND
NASHVILLE BUSTOUT, TRYING TO
GET THAT MOVING IN THE RIGHT
NICK COUSINS HAS HAD SOME GREAT
CHANCES THESE LAST COUPLE
GAMES.
NOTHING WILL GO  IS THIS GOING
CROSS ICE  OUT OF HIS REACH.
JOSI, AGAIN FROM THE POINT.
DUCHENE MISPLAYED. A BIG POWERP
TIE IT
WITH JOSI.
JOSI CHASED BY  , AN INEXPERIEN
GROUP OUT THERER
>> Chris: SOMEBODY IS FEELING
IT OUT
SISSON
THE PREDATORS LEAD FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THE GAME.GAME , O
THERE, BUT